va faire le point qui peuplent françois
hollande et julie gayet se sont mariés
ses deux sacres à paris
mabrouk à lui on est content à brands
hatch bon françois hollande mabrouk
françois comme est à dire mabrouk mazel
tov espérons jusqu'à 120 ans après huit
ans de vie commune julien gayet et
l'ancien président de la république se
sont dit oui
[Applaudissements]
à nos côtés il y en a entendu c'est bien
compliqué de caceres c'est ce que
raconte quoi continue
se sont dit oui samedi dernier à la
mairie de tulle en corrèze dont françois
hollande est le meilleur il s'est dit
comme ça je vais pas payer un maire ce
projet le faire moi-même s'agit du
premier mariage de françois hollande
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas mariés à la
ségolène royal parce que c'est le
d'ailleurs c'était ségolène royal avait
un premier mari ça sympa oui était
jabbari 5 à saint palais royal son mari
sap et couscous
[Applaudissements]
alors
on vous raconte plus moments de joie et
d'amour on en parle juste après
françois hollande et julie gayet se sont
dit oui en toute discrétion ce samedi à
tulle multiples paradis situé à 67 ans
l'ancien président de la république se
marier pour la première fois dans sa
région de prédilection la corrèze un
mariage en toute simplicité parmi les
invités le chanteur benjamin biolay un
ami du couple ça ça m'a beaucoup touché
la presse ne dit pas si les mariés sont
arrivés en scooter à la cérémonie on
leur souhaite en tout cas beaucoup de
bonheur a laissé un petit rien quand on
n'a pas grand chose on fait les
travailleurs alors géraldine est la
seule à avoir une dérogation comme vous
êtes spécialiste de julie gayet à
l'échelle 1 à dire en plus foulé avait
alors bondi dessus alors n'at il rien à
dire maintenant que je prépare ce n'est
pas le mot avant
nous les impôts d'apprendre coûtera
[Rires]
2,5 à quoi on est comme ça t'as qu'à te
recevoir voisinage ici merci d'être là
11 ans qu'ils sont ensemble donc en fait
plein de bonheur c'est un tout petit
mariage en tout petit comité il y avait
qu il y avait juste les enfants françois
avec la wii ils n'ont pas pris beaucoup
dans ce qu'ils voulaient bouffer tous
les dangers limousine et voilà il y
avait évidemment benjamin biolay donc
tout petit comité très gentil très
content artiste peintre est plein de
bonheur et j'espère que c'est tout tu te
jeter cacher le fait pour que tu dis
sauf ouais j'suis vert des gens souvent
actuelle parce qu'ils ont acheté une
maison là-bas donc s'installent là bas
elle elle tue elle arpente le marché et
c'est simplement moi ce plan mais elle
va elle fait le marché terre ils ont une
vraie vie locale donc je t'explique
shadow à te sortir progresser elle
arpente le marché
je le paie l'avenir jeu gaye et arpente
j'ai acheté une maison mais qu'est ce
que j'en ai à [ __ ] qu'ils arpentent le
marché je n'ai rien à [ __ ] qui se
marient
des présidents l'arrière foutu
gens respectueux aujourd'hui parce que
c'est parce que toi t'es pas marié
bon mariage c'est les onglets hollande
est devenu un ami en soit l'arrivée à
une amie très sympa alors oui c'est
pourquoi je compte ans que j'étais très
mauvaise langue je pensais qu'au début
de leur relation je pensais que c'était
pour déconner xve pour jouer les sales
ira nulle part dans un an ils sont ici
avec moi je me suis dis continuez c'est
quand il sera plus la maison elle va le
dégager mais voilà même chose de carla
bruni s'est en fait pas du tout mais
l'histoire d'amour au 10e et dernier à
la même chose vous rappelle à l'époque
de pupi nous
rappelle nos mobiles où j'ai pas dit que
ce à quoi j'ai là vous êtes apa jeudi
paca reste pour de mauvaises raisons
mais on dit oui quand il sera plus
président mais le quitter je rappelle
qu'un président il a encore derrière un
salaire incroyable il fait des
compensations
gardes du corps ils ont
tout d'un coup tu quand il ya de l'amour
juste que tu pars pas d'une vie de
l'elysée tout d'un coup
retiré qu'un président toi est ce que tu
pourrais avoir une aventure et françois
hollande ce qui pourrait plaire à ses
pales à une question
du président oui aujourd'hui avec les
cadres y choi ah oui françois hollande
quoi bon il est alors il est très sympa
alain il est très drôle je te dirai
intelligent et cultivé attention il peut
de séduire moi je te dis attention
françois hollande me dit tu ne dis pas
non françois hollande je te mets une
heure avec toi mykonos
mais l'honneur avec toi ni comment tu
vas vous l'aimez bien maintenant ouais
ça va c'est pas moi c'est vrai on s'est
parlé
et ça n'est pas drôle et par la série
les droits j'aimerais bien marquer sa
taille des bilans splash mois jean
lassalle a déjà déployé
sur la
butte à dire macro et macro amené le
président là la beauté en politique
c'est vrai que jusque là bas emmanueli
tout ça faisait la queue de merck ont
amené la beauté on perd oui je suis
tanné la connerie on telenor que
l'afrique n'était pas très bon en
politique m
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un beau gosse quoi ça
très beau mec de saab à roybon alors oui
qu'est ce qui se passe si vous voulez on
est on veut rien et personne n'a pas ce
côté ce côté très apprécié
cela prouve que le marché sait les
anglais mais elle arpente le marché tous
les dimanches à tulle chaque stand elle
est connue là-bas ils ont acheté une
maison qui sont très implantés
[Rires]